Good afternoon, Brenda and Brandon.
Hey, Max.
Hi, how are you doing?
Good, good. It's good to see you, man.
Yes, same here. It's in almost two months. We haven't spoken right.
Yeah, that's been a little while. Yeah.
Like last time I was not on the call. Yeah. So how are things going on?
Pretty good, I think. It's been a busy time for us, but hopefully maybe starting to get back to normal.
Nice, nice. And Brenda, I hope everything is good at your end. Your husband is doing good.
We're on the road to recovery, so it's slow, but we'll get there. I was just talking to Brandon about that, yeah.
Awesome, that's good to know.
That's good to know. I know that it's something that takes some time, but you're always like in our peers, so things will get better soon.
Thank you, we appreciate that.
Thank you very much. So before we get into a presentation, how are things going on with the engineers?
I think going well. I mean, yeah, Brenda, give your take, but I feel like we're doing better maybe than we have in a while.
I.
Yeah, it looks like it's going better. I think we still have some challenges with maybe some time sheet and making sure the utilization on our side is up because I think that was one of the issues, Brandon, correct me if I'm wrong, with some of the utilization with the engineers. So I haven't, I'll be perfectly honest with you, I haven't looked
Nice.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm.
Personally, myself yet.
Mmh.
This is really my first week, 100% kind of working from home, but being back. But I know that there was some problems, especially, I think, like with Derek, I mean, he really needs to make sure that all this, that time, and we had spoken about it before, so I'll have to double check. But that was our main thing was the utilization.
I can understand, yeah.
Mhm.
Okay, so if I'm hearing it right, like you're concerned about like he's not putting in all the time that he spends in the tickets. Did I hear it right?
Ohh.
That's what we had found before, yeah, although he comes up with 40 hours a week on our side, the utilization, you know.
OK.
Mhm, mhm.
Some of the time is just, yeah, it's not getting put on tickets. It's...
Right.
For example, from 613 to 619, that's one week, June 13th to the 19th. Our side shows he was 63.95% billable, and that's way low. That's just an example.
Mhm.
627. Now, this week, it looks like he's put in 70.71% so far as percent billable. So there may still be an issue there. And I don't think that Derek is a person that's just sitting around. So I don't, and I've stressed with him that it's very important. And if you find something that you're
Be true.
doing that you found a problem with, let me know. Either make a ticket or I'll make you a ticket or Heather make you a ticket. So I think we really do need to work on that utilization score for on our side for him. And I haven't looked at the other engineers. I think Alice is usually fine.
Mhm.
Is that?
I haven't really checked Hazel's, but...
Yeah, I do have some of the data with me. Okay, so that will also help us in ensuring that it's matching what we get at our end versus what you see at your end. So let's, that will be a good practice. So let me bring it up and then we can discuss about it.
Okay, so give me one moment. Let me bring up my presentation.
Okay, I believe it must be visible by now.
Yeah.
Perfect.
Kip.
Yeah, you want to say something, Brenda, before I start?
Yeah, I was going to say also, I believe that you guys have internal meetings on like Mondays and Thursdays and some other things going on. And Hazel, I believe it was, had told me there was some training going on. So none of that's reflected on our time sheets either. So we need to have that documented.
True.
Okay, yeah. The meetings that we pull our engineers is just a, I would say about 15 minutes meeting that I connect with the engineers on daily basis to see if anyone is facing any issues. So that's the daily meeting for just 15 minutes and that
two in case the engineers get stuck on some of the priority tickets, they can skip that part. Okay, so it's something that I connect with them formally on that bridge. Apart from that, in case they are stuck, they can skip that and we always connect offline. So that's how.
the meetings that I'm looking at right now.
Okay, I know Hazel told me there was some training, I think that she did too, when I was trying to reach out to her earlier this week, so, or maybe it was last week, yeah.
So, it will be, yeah.
That was, yeah, it was like a we.
IT by design, if you talk about as a company, we are emphasizing more on the AI. So we want all our engineers to be AI trained. So we do have our internal trainings for that. That is what engineers were going through. So we had a deadline that completed yesterday.
to go through that training. So it was not something that they had to do it in one go, but they were given enough time to complete that one. So that was, yeah. So she might be referring to that training. So that got completed and it was just, I would say, it was divided over the days not to be done in the end.
Yeah, so...
in one go, that's how it was.
I just would like to see a document. Brenda, correct me if I'm wrong, but I think it needs to be added to the time sheet. Yeah.
Mhm.
Yeah, I mean, we need to, right?
Sure, going forward, if anything of that sort comes up, because most of the trainings which engineers go through, they are the optional trainings or something that they opt in themselves. For those trainings, we do have stricter timelines and we do reach out to
the partners to get some time allocated for that training. But in case it's something which is a training which is company-wide, like this time as it was, so it was spread over one month's time. So that's why we did not reach out to you.
Okay, so going forward if anything comes up, we'll definitely let you know.
OK.
Okay, okay, so I welcome you to our monthly business review. This is the presentation in which we'll be talking about, like we will be emphasizing on June's data. So talking about, I would say, the agenda we have highlights, we'll be talking about Hazel's improvement plan.
We'll be going through the performance analysis, then our signature even build IT. I know, like Brandon has already registered for it. So just a quick glance on that part. Then we'll be talking about the way forward, the things that our engineers are going to do in next maybe couple of weeks time. And then finally,
a recap slide that is going to talk about the minutes of meeting and all the things that we discussed. I'll be updating that slide and I'll be sharing it with you in the email.
Okay, so talking about, I'll move on to the highlights. Alice handled dispatch for five days and the best part was along with the dispatch thing, she also got some good reviews. Few of them were the Google reviews from the client and I...
was aware that Turnkey Team also rewarded her for that particular Google review. So really appreciated on that particular front, and I'm sure there will be much more coming in.
Talking about Hazel taking care of the backup sheets and I would say she's updating the backup sheet and taking care of the backup statuses. She also is taking care of some of the calls which are after hours for you. However, she's in the shift, so she's taking care of those calls in case there are any.
Apart from that, if you talk about Derek, he took care of the migration of ConnectWise server that was successfully migrated, and he also worked on the wall replacement with the extension support. Anything I'm missing on over here?
No, that sounds like the big stuff.
Perfect. Moving on to the next part, Hazel's improvement plan. Like we did talk about looking in for the replacement for it. However, we are waiting on that. We have put it on hold. We want Hazel to scale up. That's what we're working on. And I just want to check
Aadika, did you notice any improvement, Brenda? Because you mentioned like she works closely with you. I know that you were not in for last two or three weeks, but like since you have joined back, anything that you might have observed that was different from last time.
Well...
But.
Not necessarily. Again, the time sheet is my main concern. I'm looking at her time sheet for this week. Monday, she put 7.64 hours. Yesterday was 6.98 hours. And I know she works an 8-hour day. So there's still some problems with that time sheet. I haven't looked back to see. It didn't look like any are standing out reject.
Mhm.
did, which is a good thing. So I haven't been able to review the timesheet, but I know that that was a big one. She did the meeting today pretty well. I would say this is just like a service meeting. I don't know, Brandon, do you have any feedback in the last couple of weeks?
Uh-huh.
Which?
I feel like she's doing the work better. You know, it's my thought. But yeah, with her, just like Derek, just like Alice, we just need to work on that utilization and make sure that they're tracking their time correctly.
Right.
Mhm.
Yep. Just to give you a heads up, like we've been helping her out or maybe we are encouraging her to be more vocal. That's what's happening behind the scenes. So I'm sure as you noticed that there was some, the last cold wind.
slightly better as compared to the last time, I'm sure those things are going to be more noticeable going forward. So that's what our primary focus is, to ensure that she gains more confidence and she's able to handle these calls in a better way. That's what our objective is and that's what we're working on in the background.
Okay, so I'll move on to the next piece for now. That is the performance analysis. This is for Alice. If you talk about last four weeks of data, one was the dispatch week. That's why it says 100% utilization over there because all the time she put in that went into the dispatching.
task. Apart from that, like if you talk about the average that turned out to be 79, that also includes like the 100% one. So that actually balanced in for the remaining weeks. So that's what it was. And she had a...
a half day off on June 19th. So that's what she achieved. And as you mentioned, that we'll be having a close eye on the utilization for not only for her, for all the engineers to ensure that they're meeting up their numbers.
Okay, so anything that you notice over here, Brenda? I know that you mentioned that you didn't have much of the time to go through the entire things. Any early observations?
Uh-uh.
I mean, I understand that time was a lot of that was done in dispatch, so that that makes sense for that.
Okay, so I'll move on to the next one then. This is for Derek. Like there were two PTOs, in fact, 1.5 days of PTOs for him on June 3rd and 16th. So that's these are the two weeks that as per data I have that he was not able to meet the target of 75.
Apart from that on, like on the first week it was on target 75, but still I expect it to be more somewhere near about 80. That is what I personally want him to achieve. Then 86 in the second one, 70 is the third one that was.
The day that he was he was off, and then eighty-five in the last week.
So anything over here that you, because this is the data till 26th of June, so that will not include last current week. Okay, so in case you're having any discrepancies for this particular week, I can definitely look that out and we can ensure.
that all the engineers are meeting their numbers.
Any questions in here before I move on to the next one?
No.
I don't.
Okay, so moving on to the next piece. This is for Hazel. First week was the week where she took two TTLs and the numbers were not met in there. However, on the subsequent weeks, she did meet the numbers. I did notice that she stayed late on.
one specific instance that was when she was working on the accent with the accent support. So that is why it is close to 99% over there. Apart from that, like predefined tickets that she's working on. So that is why we have a good, I would say.
utilization trend over here.
Are you?
Anything you want to talk about over here before I move on to next?
No.
Okay, so talking about the ticket dissolve rate, 80% is the one that Alice achieved. We have a week on week breakup in here. This is the average that she got for four. In fact, I can call it as three week because the second week it was dispatched.
So last time I remember she was handling the tickets, which she could while dispatching, but this time I didn't see any of such tickets. Maybe it was not coming up to her that she can resolve right away. So that's why I didn't see any of the tickets getting closed in that dispatch.
Okay, so moving on to the next piece, this is for Derek. Ticket resolve rate, 89% that he achieved starting with 90 and the last week was 81%, but I'm sure that he can always jump back on that. So apart from that, was a decent week for him.
But I would say a good scorecard for him, 89% on the average, that's a good one as for me, but definitely there is always room of improvement.
Hey, so any any any questions before I move on to Hazel's resolve rate?
Me.
K.
There, go ahead.
Talking about Hazel, as I mentioned, she's working on the predefined or pre-assigned tickets, majority of them. So 90% is the ticket resolve rate that she achieved. If you talk about the week on week starting with 92, 91, then
a slight dip for 84% and then jump back to 95% on the last week.
Hey, any questions?
No.
Okay, so now talking about our, I would say, the events that we're talking about. So Brandon, you are registered, so it's only you who is going to be attending Build ITBD this year, or will it be anyone else as well?
I think it's just me. Pretty sure.
Okay, I did see only one registration, so maybe any last minute adjustments you want to make? You want to maybe add more people in there?
I'll have to ask around, but it may just be me this time.
Okay, no worries. So do let us know in case anything changes. We can definitely look out for the last minute adjustments if they are required. So just to bring it up over here, AI by Design, the one that we are talking about over here, this is going to be part of our build ITBD event itself. So like.
As you're aware, August is the month. So AI by Design will be part of the Build ITBD on the third day. So that's going to be included into the Build ITBD event.
OK.
Okay, so as I mentioned, let us know in case any changes are to be made and we can definitely look into in case you need some more people to be registered.
All right.
Okay, so talking about Team GPS, so you are already using it, so I'm sure there will be new features added to it. And once you are at Build IT, you will be able to see the latest features in there. So in case you have any questions, maybe you want to know about more features.
Let us know, I can go ahead and schedule a call.
Okay, so talking about way forward, check-ins are going to continue. Hazel to focus on backup and patching as she's doing. Derek will be working on the 3x4 security update and also working on the firewall configuration issues that will be
Okay.
something on the agenda for him and Alice to work on the Helpdesk tickets as well as in case any audits are required. She always takes care of that and she will be working on those as well.
Anything I may be missing in here that you have aligned for these engineers?
Uh, not on my side.
Yeah, I don't think so.
Okay.
Okay, no worries. Let us know and we can always take care of that in case anything is needed. So that brings us to the end of our presentation. I thank you. I thank both of you for your time today to going through this presentation. Let me stop presenting my screen and any
Anything you want to add in before we wrap it up?
Mm.
No, I don't think so.
Okay, so Brenda, anything from your side?
No, not not not anything that I didn't mention already.
Okay, perfect. And we do have Kavan with us. Kavan, anything you want to add in before we wrap it up?
Hey, Manish. Hey, Brandon. Hey, Brenda. Good to hear your voice, even though I don't see you, but that's okay. I know.
Hey, Callan.
Hi, Juan.
Ha ha ha!
Mm.
I hope things are well on your end. Manish is doing what he's supposed to do, right, supporting the team. And from your end, we are happy that you're supporting the team as well. So yeah, nothing from my end. And we will, as we all know that you are registered to build it, so we would love to see you there.
Alright, yes indeed.
Thank you, Manish, showed you.
Thank you, Colin. Thank you, Brenda and Brandon. Thank you for your time today. And we'll catch up next time. Do let us know in case anything is required from my end.
Will do. Thank you, Max.
Okay.
Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you. Have a great day.
Thank you, Brandon. Thank you, Brenda. Take care. Bye bye.
Mhm.
Thanks.
Bye.